i didn't expect the interview to go this
way but you mentioned i didn't know this
that you'd left the labor party because
of
of their uh allegations of anti-semitism
i am someone who's
i'm very wary now because the the labels
of racist get thrown around so much
i don't even automatically believe it
you know when people call someone racist
i'm like well
i i don't know are they are they not but
you're obviously someone who's been
inside the party
so tell us you know what what are the
the reasons that you left what are some
of the evidence for for these
allegations
well well i i don't think jeremy corbyn
sits there thinking i'm an anti-semite
i'm now going to do anti-semitic things
i don't think that
so i don't think in that sort of
conscious proud racism round up the jews
yes yes i don't think any of that i
don't think that i think his
he ends up being an anti-semite out of a
series of other convictions so he
believes that
imperialism is the most important and
potent force in world politics
he believes that america is a driving
force of that imperialism and he
believes that american capitalism is a
beneficiary
of its conquests around the world the
most so notable imperial state
in that analysis is israel because it's
caught in the midst of a whole series of
others
and it is oppressing when it's the
puppies of america and he's
that set of convictions plus an
exaggerated sense that this is the most
important thing of all
human history leads him to a position of
such
hostility to what he would call zionism
that he is then blind to
what is overt anti-semitism so if you
look at the mural on the wall for
example
he didn't see anything wrong anyone else
would see it straight away
sorry could you just describe that a
little bit the murals there are america
it was a mural
a mural was painted on a wall in east
london with a whole series of very
blatant anti-semitic caricatures
on it all money lenders and usury and it
was all
implying that the the jews it was
implying a world rothschild type
jewish financial conspiracy and it was
as
clear as day that that's what was being
depicted
uh jeremy corbyn shared that mural a
picture of that mural on the facebook
group didn't really notice it
and so i think he becomes blind to those
things
he also because of that he licenses
the entry into the labour party are
people who really are overt
over the anti-semitic so the there's
always been a very small minority of
people
on the hard left who are anti-semitic
that always has been
i mean i don't mean to imply by that
there aren't some terrible racists on
the right of course there's a thousand
and you know different types but hating
jews as a bipartisan issue
it absolutely is it absolutely i mean
right now the conservative artists
problem is more with
um islam yes with islam than it is with
um
with judaism but you know we're not
choosing which which is the best racism
i think they're both quite bad but the
one that which which i
could because i was a member of the
labor party this one is particularly
pertinent to me
and so those people those overt
anti-semites
are now members of the labour party
whereas once upon a time they weren't
and so i think the
the party's been really infected with
this
and the response to it has been very
very slow
and i just felt i don't have it's not a
once and for all thing i can rejoin the
labour party
if and when this is eradicated as a
problem but i thought i don't want to be
a member of it
whilst this is there and not being taken
seriously enough
so just i don't mean to make a great
fanfare of it but i just think there we
are
no it's just i i really wanted to ask
you about it because it's something that
we keep hearing about but
i've never heard anyone sum sum it up
quite so succinctly and kind of explain
what the allegations are what's the
substance because i think it's quite
important to be as generous to
the people you're concerned as you can
um yeah
because i don't think it's as i said
before i'm not accusing
jeremy corbyn of being a racist i think
that's ridiculous
so i think everything i've said is
compatible with his claim that
he's an anti-racist campaigner and of
course he is in one sense and
spent his life protesting against
various oppressions and injustices and i
i don't i don't want to wash away that
record but i just think he has a blind
spot here where his
various causes clash
and he ends up in a position which i
think is really dreadful
and i don't want to be a member of a
party which has that
feeling so there's the it's a hard left
sensibility which i
just don't want to be part of the labour
party
but it is they are the governing
force in the labour party and you can
either choose to stay there and try and
win it back and engage in that fight
it's not my fight anymore because i'm
not active in politics and i thought
actually better off just to
to have the freedom to criticize by
coming out
and then i can be honest about it you're
outside the tent
i'm outside the temple yeah pissing on
it
[Music]
you